[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay say something hey how's it going
pretty good so we're here this is the
first episode of wisdom for life a new
show that's devoted to talking about
philosophy and how it can be made
practical yeah what we are talking about
here a lot is going to be practical
philosophy and how that differs from the
kind of idea of what is academic
philosophy exactly so we've got a lot of
cool stuff lined up for this hour and
we'll give you a little rundown of that
but first I think we will introduce
ourselves so let me introduce my co-host
Dan Hayes
you can tell you a little bit about
himself so I'm the co organizer of the
Milwaukee snow fellowship and I'm I also
run a weekly Stoke meetup on the
Humboldt collective it is Sunday
mornings yeah Dan is kind of
underselling himself a bit he does a lot
of organizing when it comes to practical
philosophy stuff here in the Milwaukee
area I do what I can and and the
illustrious professor Greg Sadler oh
thanks yeah so I I'm somebody who
started out in academia doing philosophy
and you know the traditional academic
way teaching classes and then I started
realizing how useful it could be in a
lot of different contexts and now you
know we we have a lot of cool stuff
going on in here in Milwaukee we have
the stoic fellowship that Dan and I are
both leading I guess you'd say you know
cool going with co-organizers yeah and
there's other things going on as well
there's a group called Sofia Milwaukee
which is devoted public philosophy and
there's a events around the year so
we'll probably talk about some of those
on the show we should probably talk a
little bit about how you know how we got
the idea for doing the show as well
yeah so why don't you tell us that story
Greg well we'd been kicking the idea
around for quite a while right well yeah
we thought maybe a podcast or something
along those lines and then we got the
opportunity here yeah and you know River
West radio is community radio so it's
it's perfectly suited to this this sort
of endeavor because we can offer a
rather unique voice that probably I
don't think there's anything like this
in the Midwest right now I don't know
it's all that the local stations that
were popping up in what the mid-2000s
and yeah you know it really gives a
voice for the community but yeah we came
here and we had a really great Christmas
special that's right all day special you
know on talking about why it's good to
give ya and generosity is a virtue and
when you want to give and when you don't
want to give and all those those sorts
of things and we looked at it from a
philosophical perspective mostly
informed by it by stoicism which is
which is something that Dan and I have
in common but bringing in some other
perspectives as well and we like being
on the radio so much that we decided to
make it a regular thing so we're going
to be here every other Friday so I go
ahead and from 5 to 6 p.m.
talking for an hour yeah and we'll have
different topics this this first episode
we thought we would introduce ourselves
and talk a little bit about what the
show is going to be about in general
terms and so we have some things already
lined up but one of the things I do want
to point out is each show that at least
so far as we've got it in mind right now
will probably close out the show by
talking about an actionable
philosophical practice that you could
put into practice right after finishing
the show and or listening to the show
and it'll be drawn from ancient or
medieval or modern philosophy and we'll
put it into terms that are easy to
understand and we'll also be looking at
questions from the community exactly
yeah
real life issues that can be illuminated
by by philosophy not not totally solved
but at least we can get some guidelines
on how to deal with them and we've got
you know thousands of years of history
and people deep thinking about these
ideas and you know the human condition
hasn't changed all that much on a really
macro level that's right
yeah it's surprising this is it's a just
a little bit of experiential stuff I've
been teaching philosophy classes for
about 20 years now and one of the cool
experiences that I have is about
students having a certain kind of
experience themselves which is they you
know let's tape to stick Plato right
they read Plato and I have them read
Plato's Republic and there they grown a
bit I got to read this old text and then
they read what's going on and say in
book four where Plato's talking about
these three parts of the soul and
theological stuff you know then and then
they read it and they're like oh wait a
second this is psychology and man this
this actually you know it may not be
exactly the right way to look at it but
this is this illuminates a lot of stuff
for me this make helps me make sense of
things and we see those aha moments and
then there's more that can come out of
it you said well if you like that you
could you could read this as well it's
really gratifying so the question is
which horse are you or that's the why a
trees yeah yeah well I've always you
know I'm gonna use a term here and we're
always gonna try to define terms as best
as we can so that you don't have to have
a you know background in philosophy in
order to understand this but I'm gonna
say I'm a thematic kind of person
meaning that in plato's terms I'm driven
by this middle part of the soul which is
the part with which we experience
courage but also anger and you know
respond to potential threats or insults
or things like that
so that has been my background that's
why I got into researching anger
management using ancient philosophy so
I'll kind of cop to that right off the
I am not you know as a person I'm not
really the rational charioteer in the
model that Plato uses in the Phaedrus
I'm more the good horse at least I'm not
the bad horse hey what about you Dan
which are you oh I'm I definitely used
to be the little bit more of the bad
horse and no driven by your appetites
and passion more than anything okay and
then and that that chaos and just but
you know life happens and you learn new
things and you realize that there are
better ways about going about your life
and so that is definitely something I've
well that's a nice segue right there
yeah yeah talking a little bit more
about philosophy so you know for our
listeners to get a sense of how you got
into I mean they know that I got into it
through academic philosophy what drew
you into studying philosophy and in
particular what drew you into stoicism
okay so I was at university on
University of Wisconsin and I was doing
an all-nighter working on a
bioinformatics project and about 3 a.m.
I just needed to not look at my code
anymore I need to look at something else
to just clear my mind and not be
thinking about that and had been
following a podcast that brought up
stoicism I thought that was kind of
sounded interesting I brought up this
page that was referenced in this podcast
and I'm like reading like just the
really basics of stoicism I'm like oh oh
yes that that makes sense and that makes
sense and that's exactly how I used to
react to things and I really should
react to them and just a little bit
better way and this seems to be a really
interesting path forward and maybe this
will work out and so that was like my
aha moment that's that's good you know
interestingly when I first encountered
stoicism I didn't have quite the same
reaction I I you know and again I was
you know in academic context and I was
probably I don't know if I was younger I
was in my early 20s
and I you know I read Epictetus is
uncrating and Marcus's meditations and I
was very drawn to the like you know
resiliency and toughness and don't let
things get to you but all the notion of
like well you know you gotta be just and
wise I wasn't that much it's not our
temperance I was definitely not into
temperance when I was in college yeah
but you know I found you found some guys
out in California while I was sleeping
out there that we're also meeting as
regular Stoics early that seems like
they had a pretty well organized group
right yeah well there's there like three
stoke groups in the San Francisco Bay
Area itself but I was with the Fremont
Stoics you know actually before we jump
into the topic that we're gonna schedule
to at this point what do you think what
do you think the value of having like
meetups or local local groups where you
can actually talk about philosophy with
other people that are not necessarily
all that learn it in it but are better
interested in it what what value did
that provide you with the very least you
know community we're all looking for
that that group of people that kind of
understands you and we're all going
through different paths in life and on
if you're you're trying to use
philosophy as a way of life which we'll
get to in just a moment on the that it's
really useful to have other people that
are also on trying to do this this
project and to kind of compare notes
yeah that makes that makes total sense
to me the knowing that you're not the
only person in the room who's into
something there's something about that
that's particularly compelling you know
supportive helpful to people we are
really you know fundamentally social
creatures exactly yeah so um well let's
talk about how philosophy is becoming
kind of a bigger thing
well not academically unfortunately a
lot of philosophy departments
including my alma mater 'z are really
having a rough time you know the place
where I went to undergraduate no longer
has a philosophy degree hasn't had it
for a long time the place rated my
graduate studies their department has
shrunk terribly because it's been you
know underfunded in Illinois for so long
so you know academic philosophy having a
rough time right but that's not the
point of this program well right so so
so philosophy is doing pretty good
outside of the Academy I mean we could
say well that's because the Internet and
the fact that people can now connect
with each other and find resources all
over the world and I think that's part
of it but what it what else do you think
is is driving that well I feel like it
comes down to the we have turned
philosophy into this kind of stuffy no
ivory tower idea at least that's what
the the common idea of what we call
philosophy nowadays is and and we moved
away from more the ancient understanding
of philosophy which is you having a
specific idea of the world and how you
should act within it and trying daily to
you know act your values yeah that's you
know this is a bit of a side note but
what there's there been quite a few
scandals within the ethics community the
academic ethics community where people
who are doing academic philosophy and
specializing in ethics you find out that
they do these terrible things and then
something you know people reasonably
said well what good is ethics if it's
not actually making the people not just
the students who are studying it but the
people who are actually teaching it if
it's not gonna make them better people
and I I think a lot of that has to do
with the walking the walk you know daily
practice there's there's a lot of people
who conceive of philosophy as kind of
this like you said you know it's it's
it's an elite activity it's for people
who are gonna put in their their time
and then they they go on and do whatever
they're gonna do it's not really part of
their life yeah so when we actually make
it part of our lives and you
set now like oh well you know we should
have a little bit of wisdom and courage
and justice in our lives how do you
actually make that that seems like a
really kind of pie in the sky idea and
how do we bring that back down to earth
yeah you know and it's interesting well
let you know let's take stoicism as an
example so you mentioned these these
things that we call the cardinal virtues
of wisdom temperance justice and courage
and there's there's other names for them
that we could use like moderation for
temperance which is kind of an
old-fashioned name a lot of people like
to substitute an old-fashioned name
fortitude for courage yeah but well you
know it's it's it's really all the same
thing and so you say to people okay so
you know you you should aim for these
these virtues this is a good thing for
you it'll make you have a better life
and then they say yeah but what about
kindness and this is something that we
talked about previously you know if you
read the stoic texts you find out that
while kindness was actually part of
justice but if you're just going by sort
of a surface thumbnail kind of read then
you'd say well I don't know this is
really for me it seems like it doesn't
cover all the things that we want it to
to help us out well how dare you be not
benevolent how is that not something
that's part of your like course but it
is that's yeah I mean if it were true
that would be a legitimate beef right
with this right and so you know more
reading more more study of the
particular philosophical texts often
reveals all sorts of cool features of
the philosophy to us that then help
people to integrate these these things
and so that into their life you know I I
kind of agree with you that philosophy
recently got turned and we'll use the
the old catch phrase an ivory tower yes
sort of thing right and I think that for
a long time you know for maybe like the
70s and 80s it was it was quite popular
in philosophy departments to like pride
themselves on how inaccessible they were
to to everybody else I was like
Heidegger yeah well I I'm nothing about
Heidegger so much but
that I mean he certainly would fit in
there he's earlier but he had people
interpreting him but I'm thinking about
more the typical American and British
philosophers who had you know more
probably more talking more about how to
interpret Vidkun Stein or Russell or
hair people like that or then later on
people who are more contemporary with
them like rile and they talked about
philosophy as if it's something that
ought not have shouldn't have to justify
itself right and that's always a bad
sign when when when you're when you're
doing that because if you can't explain
what you're doing and why you're doing
it to other people you know if you can't
provide a rational account then why
should they why should they pay for you
to do it right and so when there's
plenty of money flowing into
universities well then you could afford
to be elitist but as soon as there's
budget crises that means that philosophy
would be on the chopping block right so
so I think that we're gonna see less and
less of that sort of thing and more and
more of what we're doing here which is
trying to try to make philosophy
practical and public and popular and and
you can see in the public stage the the
a practical philosophy or public
philosophy has been growing there's
still groups exploding all over the
United States as well as in Europe and
they are know as well as there are the
new Epicureans and us of all the groups
you know you're talking about what the
randi ins and yeah I mean you know you
could you could look at all sorts of
movements and so I would say that among
the Hellenistic philosophies stoicism in
the sense of you know modern stoicism
very broadly speaking trying to have
contemporary interpretations of it has
been the most successful there's like
you said there's there's groups popping
up almost monthly now across the world
and there's a you know an annual stoic
on and and one way that you can tell the
movement is really doing well is when
there's there's like factions within it
who can be opposed to each other and say
you've got the wrong interpretation so
there's the traditional Stoics who say
that the modern Stokes have got it all
wrong but the traditional Stoics are
contemporary people as well they just
you know they're a little bit more
committed to the
the theology yes and and then you're
right the Epicureans actually that a new
book came out just this last year how to
be an epicurean by Catherine Wilson but
there was another really good book by
Hyrum Crespo who's down in Chicago
cultivating the epicurean garden a
couple years back and they have groups
as well much smaller and then you know
there's there's Facebook groups
associated with these I think that any
any maybe if they had bigger gardens
well I mean the goal is to like and and
and you know ensconced yourself in this
garden so nothing can get to you so yeah
it's too big yeah and you know if you
have to do a lot of work to cultivate it
I don't know that that's I don't know
that's a little line with what they work
that too they don't value work for its
own sake so I hear that gardening is
enjoyable from time to time that's true
yeah yeah and and yeah there's a lot of
other going concerns let's say you know
different communities that that offer
philosophy as something that you would
you would commit yourself to and
practice it's it's not as if it's not
rigorous because there's there's text
there's thinkers there's you know ideas
that have to be studied and and and
worked upon and sometimes reinterpreted
you know to deal with new problems but
it's it's vital and that that sense of
community that we are talking about at
the beginning is very important as well
so this kind of leads us to the idea of
philosophy of as a way of life and what
does it actually mean so we were using
the term or the the title of the book by
the French philosopher Pierre hadou on
and his deep reading of what the ancient
philosophers were actually doing and so
this is actually kind of one of the main
places where modern philosophy kind of
relearned what it meant to be a
philosopher in the ancient sense to
actually be that person that is trying
to live a way of life yeah and when we
say modern in this case we we really
mean very late moderns like 19th and
20th
century because I don't point out that
there were the you know he's looking at
the ancients primarily but he points out
that the existentialists are also very
committed to philosophy as a way of life
he points out a number of other other
movements along the way and I think that
we could even take somebody who's kind
of in many people's eyes a boogie man of
philosophy as a way of life they think
it's very abstract and very disconnected
from life Rene Descartes
right to be accused of being a Cartesian
is a very bad thing not only in
philosophical circles but in in sort of
academic circles generally right but
Descartes himself if you read his
writings especially if you read his
letters and then you read like the
introductions to his works he saw what
he was doing as a a philosophical
project that would you know transform
the way people lived it was it was very
practically oriented there there's a lot
of you know theory involved and it's
pretty cool stuff to teach and to talk
about but he thought that he was gonna
transform the world and make it better
by the way that he was proposing doing
philosophy you know with a fresh start
and round up rebuild yeah exactly yeah
yeah and so I think that this this
notion of philosophy as something that
would be lived it's not something
foreign to most of the history of
philosophy or rather let's say most of
philosophies history because we could we
can make a distinction there history of
philosophy is kind of a specialty where
you're like trying to figure out well
why did Descartes actually say this
thing was he influenced by this guy at
this time and that can be kind of you
know it's it's fun stuff but it doesn't
really reach ordinary people I think but
if you bring up say like des cartes
rules of method in in his discourse and
you set them out and then you you know
this is what I do with undergraduates
when I'm teaching it I say now how would
this actually work in your discipline
you're going into nursing how would you
approach it as a Cartesian and you know
the light bulb comes on well that's a
sign that there is something connecting
there they're there this this could be
lived as a way of life David
Hume saw philosophy that way we teach
these people as if they're you know
they're engaging in philosophy in the
20th century in an academic sense but
really what they were trying to do is
think about philosophy and a much
broader sense in which it could
transform our lives and and help us you
know make progress towards whatever we
are doing and get ourselves out of some
silly errors and so you know I do as you
mentioned focuses a lot on ancient
philosophy we probably will too but
there there's a lot of other experts
throughout the history yeah yeah so when
we are talking about this is a lot of it
is you know choosing certain values in
which are important and like is there a
hierarchy of these values on and you
know depending on the school or you know
your own may be eclectic version of
these things that you have to make some
sort of decisions about what you're
going to follow and um to make a
commitment to actually follow through on
these day in and day out yeah I like
that that you brought up a hierarchy of
values we can talk about prioritization
right right a term that we usually use
in contemporary stuff we don't think of
it in terms of you know philosophy is
helping us to prioritize better but
you're right the ancients you know they
say well think about these really
fundamental things that people desire
some people really do just want to have
a good time so that you know pleasure or
avoidance of pain and trouble and you
know having security other people want
to make a million bucks and you know
they think that if you just can make a
lot of money or have income streams
coming in or you know whatever it
happens to be be richer than the
neighbor next door that's that's having
made that's happiness others said
friendship relationships having those
you know harmonious that that could be
good and then there's lots of other
things and how you you know in ancient
times they recognized that there's only
so many different ways you can configure
these there's only so many this is like
a combinatoric
right right we think about it in
mathematical terms you only got so many
options and you could you've got to
think about well which one are you gonna
put ahead of which or are you just gonna
kind of like throw them all in the air
and let them land wherever they happen
to land and which which school you pick
it determines at least the the answer
how you ought to prioritize and then you
then you're stuck with the fact that you
know what the blueprint is and you look
at yourself and you put that blueprint
as sort of like superimposed on yourself
and you're like well this is a mess yeah
you know this this doesn't meet the
blueprints at all how would I do this
how would I how would I actually make
any progress towards say if I want to
say that being a good person moral
virtue right virtue of character if
that's really what's good and I look at
myself I could do this today and say
well you know I'm okay on this front but
not on that there's a lot of work to be
done
how do you do the work and so that's
that's kind of the main point this whole
radio show is how to do the work how to
do the work yeah and we're not giving
you answers that we're like coming up
with just on the spot hopefully they're
gonna be informed to some degree by
philosophy and so we don't actually have
to do that much heavy lifting no thanks
thankfully there's a lot of guys you sat
around and try to figure out the human
condition and women to Mary
Wollstonecraft you know great example
yeah yeah so on to try to figure out the
inner workings of what makes a good life
and yeah once we have an idea of what
makes a good life then they spent a lot
more time trying to figure out the best
ways to getting there and so we are here
to try to offer to you some of their
wisdom passed down that's a good way to
put it yeah so philosophy is a way of
life is experiential you know you it
does involve some reading and some study
but it involves putting things into
practice and then seeing what the
results are and sometimes you know you
can know something intellectually you
can all cash you do this thing and
here's
supposed to work but until you actually
try it out and usually fail at it a
couple times and then figure out what
you did wrong and then get it to work
you don't really know it right and the
first step at being sort of good at
something is sucking at something so we
all start off at the bottom we won't
work that's true yeah yeah but the idea
is to have a little bit of fortitude or
courage to try it to persevere to
persevere yeah see if it actually works
yeah you know that's that's actually
another good thing to point out and I'm
sure we'll talk about this plenty in
other episodes a lot of people want
instant results and you know I'll bring
up another term that's that's been
floating around a lot that is kind of
connected to philosophy as a way of life
but but could actually block the road to
it and that's the notion of life hack
right all right so people people you
know there's all sorts of articles out
there mostly having to do with stoicism
but I think you could find them on
others like how to hack your life and
you know transform it by using Marcus
Aurelius reading him for ten minutes a
day well you're probably gonna have to
read him more than 10 minutes a day you
know and you're gonna have to like do
stuff and it should be systematically
connected with things and you'll have to
like do some taking stock each day and
see whether you're making any progress
or not but this is this life hack
mentality it's you know what the promise
seems to be like well it's almost like
taking a pill right or flipping a switch
get that instant gratification yeah that
that's that's right it doesn't just fix
things it makes you feel better right
but sometimes feeling better isn't the
path actually making your life better
yeah well special if you've screwed it
up yeah and let's do the Epicureans and
then well even they are willing to say
there are some cases where you really do
have to you know as we say rip off the
band-aid and take the the pain so that
you can improve like you know for so for
example people think about Epicureans
they hear this term and they're like oh
you know that means partying all the
time and the ancient Epicureans didn't
do that
right because what happens when you
party all the time well you know you get
hungover or you can't figure out where
you left your car or you know you wake
up next to somebody and you're not sure
who they are and these these are not
things that make your life better right
especially once your app 2:30 very true
the body has much less tolerance for
those sort of shenanigans right but oh
god no just it's it's you know deferred
pain you know you spend a night drinking
in the next day dealing with that and
you know yeah a debt that is you know
gets more and more larger and larger you
know your pay back every year and there
are some exceptions people whose bodily
Constitution is you know stronger than
the average you know think about Lemmy
from from Motorhead who you know it
reputedly drink like a fifth of whiskey
a day and he smoked all sorts of
cigarettes and he'd get up you know and
not no problem he get up on stage and do
his thing and then when he found out
that he was sick he I think he cut back
from a certain amount of liquor to a
smaller amount of liquor I mean that
would that would kill me not to do that
sort of thing I think even in my
twenties that would have killed me that
sounds like it was definitely a
functioning alcoholic yeah yeah yeah a
very high performer do oh you know sure
you can be a performer and a functioning
alcoholic doesn't mean it's a
particularly good state to be in in as a
matter of fact in in some respects being
able to get away with something like
that is actually a disadvantage hmm
because you come to rely on it I'll give
you an example from my own life so when
I was in my teens and 20s I was you know
I was eating a lot you know like
probably anywhere from 5,000 to 6,000
calories a day but I was also exercising
an awful lot you know sometimes three
four hours a day and because that was
very important to me at the time you
know it's very invested in being strong
and body image and it felt good to do
and
and I made the mistake as I moved into
my 30s of not not tempering the amount
that I was eating the enjoyment that I
was taking in food right and I wasn't
exercising as much and you know you it's
almost like mathematics right so many
calories going in so many calories going
out if you don't expend them they're
gonna you know accumulate and they
accumulate and in fat so you know
there's there's all sorts of ways that
people do that where they they find
something that's functional for them at
one point in their life and it may be
very pleasurable and then they don't
goes on autopilot exam re-examine the
thing and one of the big things that we
find I'd say a good the spiritual
practice or which is the next topic here
yeah is the idea of taking assessment
every day or you know maybe weekly or
monthly assessments to see what you are
doing and make sure that they are not
are they are actually appropriate for
the what you need at the moment honest
assessments oh yes because it doesn't do
any good if you if you you know can
ahead a little bit on what's going out
of your life you have to be looking at
it it might actually be helpful to have
somebody else involved in the assessment
project at certain points to give you
some guidance and say no now you lose
your temper a lot more often than you
think you do yes and that's that's
another reason why we should have a
community yeah looking through these
things yeah we we are so good at fooling
ourselves into thinking that we are you
know better than we might think
yeah or were less worse that's bad yeah
so spiritual practices um I believe as a
coin also by hud oh yeah on which he was
going through specifically Marcus
Aurelius in really deep fashion he was
trying to figure out what this
particular work was and he finally
dawned upon him that this was him
writing to himself every day or every
morning about the
the things that he is either trying to
do that day or a reflection on the
things that he had done that day and all
the things that he was preparing to do
that day were also other spiritual
practices so yeah and we should mention
so mark Marcus Aurelius meditations is a
work that's not very systematic and so
you know why would how do I have to
figure out what's going on because the
work is frankly speaking kind of a mess
when you read it right Airy it's all
over the place so it makes it makes good
sense that he'd zero in on that and addo
uses this word spiritual so he's writing
in French and in French the term spirit
s plea means what we think usually think
of a spirit but it also means mind so
you could think of these as mental
practices as well if you want to use it
that that term they are things that are
supposed to be transforming the person
helping them understand who they are
helping them develop towards towards
their their good and there's a whole
variety of them right so from from all
the different schools you know if you're
trying to do yeah one thing you set
certain values up because you're
following one school then there's a set
of practices for that yeah and you know
it's it's interesting too you don't have
to like it's not as if you have to pick
a school and then you can only read
their stuff and think about that I mean
you can steal stuff from other schools
Seneca is a prime example of somebody
who not only does that but also justify
his history because he any and he takes
it from the school that's most directly
opposed to the Stoics the Epicureans but
the justification is well they got
something good over there let's let's
make it our own and so you know usually
talking about like you know ideas and
want to be spread yeah yeah they don't
they're they're sort of a common
Commonwealth of humankind right right
yeah you should not reserve yourself
only to one school or one teacher or one
thought yeah and and so yeah spiritual
practices what you know what are they
they they are thing
that we do and usually they can be
framed in terms of you know a couple
sentences to a paragraph do these things
in this way we're actually gonna explore
one of them towards the end of the show
that we call negative visualization just
to give you an idea about how these
these things work and you know you do
them sometimes daily sometimes you know
less frequently sometimes many times a
day and you can get better at them you
can do them you know more effectively
and over time they they produce
transformations in you and the
transformations can be cognitive and
what we think or what we understand they
can be effective that is in how we feel
things or what we desire and they can
also help us to develop new habits and
to break old habits that are getting in
our way and I think another dimension
that often gets left out they change our
relationships or offer new possibilities
for relationships for us both with
ourselves and others exactly yeah so one
that you know many people might be aware
of is you know within the Buddhist
tradition you know papasano or
mindfulness meditation was a very strong
you know spiritual practice it would say
hey looking into the inner workings of
your mind and trying to be more aware of
that as well as your feeling within the
world yeah and now let's talk about that
a little bit so it's a good thing to do
at various points right you encounter
something that's annoying or something
you could stop and then well what's
what's actually going on here with me
but it's also something that people
would deliberately do on a schedule
right right so you can either I fall
into it in a experience where it might
be useful for a immediate reassessing of
the situation that you're in or you know
sit down and do your tan or hour-long
meditation and the more you do with a
lot of meditation yeah yeah I mean there
you're talking about like what only a
few monks can do
but I mean the rest of us can do all
sorts of shorter ones we can break it up
and and still derive the benefits from
it and by doing it regularly you're
setting yourself up to be able to do it
spontaneously when you're in a situation
all right right allow you to kind of
drop into that headspace yeah there's
another thing that the Stoics over and
over again say have X whatever X happens
to be ready at hand and they usually
means some saying but it's actually not
just a saying it's also a practice
so like when Epictetus says you know
have ready at hand these these different
things so when you encounter a troubling
situation you can for example say to
something that's appearing to you to be
the way it is let me let me have a
little bit of a pause here let's see
whether you're actually representing
things as they are having that verbal
phrase is helpful right it's not just
something that you feel or do it's
something that you can explain to
another person or explain to yourself
yeah it's people suffer more in thought
than a reality oh yeah at hand phrase
yeah although that's better to have at
hand for yourself than to console
somebody who's Curly's right so this is
a good segue I'm right um so we have a
question that has been submitted for the
show today yeah and actually I'm drawing
this from one of the Facebook groups
which which talks about stoicism where
people bring up common life problems and
it runs like this I've been studying
stoicism for about a year now and I've
been able to make some positive changes
in my thinking I wonder where the line
is between ignoring something and
allowing yourself to be a doormat and
the this there's a little bit more to it
but I think that's a good launching
point there's a lot of people who
you know get involved in stoicism and
and they do so because they're drawn to
it because it seems to promise a
resilience in the face of problems but
then there's you know there's this
notion that it means just accepting
anything that happens to you and well
what if people are jerks to you mm-hmm
what do you do and so this seems to be a
common misconception of the full breadth
of the philosophy and so it's a two
pieces two major pieces you have a kind
of this idea of the dichotomy of control
that the things that are under your
control are on the things that actually
matter and life and things that are
outside someone other people's actions
aren't things that have any effect on
what your virtue is or what your how you
should be experienced in the world you
shouldn't be upset with how other people
act around you that and so they get into
this kind of rut of thinking that this
is the only way of looking at things
when in fact there's another big portion
of stoicism with is this discipline of
action that it's not that you on should
be passive and not act at that
particular moment because it shouldn't
affect you or how you feel but that it
is the ability for you then to act in
the proper way without being disturbed
by how other people are acting yeah and
we should talk a little bit about the
dichotomy of control I mean we'll do
we'll probably do a whole show on it
later on down the line
absolutely so this is a like Dan was
saying and absolutely you know central
stoic idea gets gets gets formulated
explicitly by epictetus who's a late
start but it seems to have played a big
role prior to that and the idea is that
there's there's some things that are in
our control or inner power or literally
are up to us and then there's other
things that aren't
and they draw the line at a place where
a lot of us maybe wouldn't saying that
our bodies aren't in our control or
money our reputation other people's
actions how other people think about us
none of those things are actually in our
control they don't mean that of course
that you have no possible way of you
know influencing these but it's you know
whatever you do could could go astray so
if I want Dan to think I'm a small guy
and he doesn't think so I can do all
sorts of nice things you know buy em
chocolates
take them out for drinks or something
like that give them a glowing review on
Facebook whatever I'm sorry I'm just you
know I'm pervious to your charms over
there yeah exactly talk about you know
and and and he can say well I don't like
this guy you know there's nothing you
can actually do about it and then what
what is in our control our thoughts our
desires are our choices all of the
things that we think of as core to us
the kind of people that we want to be
and then that does seem to lay people I
think feel like that lays them in for
being insulted or humiliated or treated
wrong and then they're you know a stoic
who I think doesn't quite get it would
use some of the lines or they say well
you you think you're insulted no that's
just your thought it's your not really
being insulted it's it's only you know
the the viewpoint that you have on it
and that's kind of true but also kind of
not true if I decide so I'm sitting
across from Dan right now if I decide I
want to say nasty things to him I'm
actually saying nasty things now whether
he let's hit that effect him or not
that's up to him right but it doesn't
change the fact that I'm being a jerk
right things objectively speaking right
and I can tell you you're being a jerk
and you really shouldn't do that what's
out without actually feeling angry that
he was saying those things to me yeah so
let's talk about what what seems to be
the kind of the common issue in this
question it's about setting boundaries
right right so can you set boundaries
reasonably without allowing yourself to
get upset with
boundaries are crossed or when the
person makes fun of you for setting the
boundaries or whatever else we want to
say about that
and the answer is yeah yeah absolutely
you have to be able to know where your
boundaries are and oh that's a good
point so so this is where the the you
know stoic conception of justice would
come in right there's some things that
we probably even though we could like
not allow them to get to us we probably
shouldn't allow people to do them to us
there being a stoic doesn't mean that
you have to endure abuse forever and
ever and ever to show everybody what a
stoic you are you know I mean if you if
you were trying to evangelize for
stoicism I guess that could be a good
thing but that's that's the straw straw
man argument for what it is ya know why
you don't tell people what a straw man
is a straw man is when you make you take
someone else's position and you make a
on the worst possible case for it and so
you're making a straw fake
representation of what that argument is
and then you say oh look at this bad
argument I can easily knock that down
without actually dealing with the
substance of the idea that the other
person is actually holding so how is
this how is this straw Manning I mean
this is kind of like you're on your
straighter bulken you're you're a Vulcan
is like a really bad understanding of
stoicism and he's like he's totally
unemotional and he lets absolutely
nothing on interact with them and here's
purely logical yeah on and except for
that one period we're talking of course
about in the Star Trek universe where
they're hormones like go haywire and
then they turn into just like mindless
brutes right yeah well I mean actually
it's it you know so this is actually a
great launching point the goal of any
philosophy of life that's worth doing is
not to like cut off or you know
repress things about ourselves that that
we we think are particularly good there
may be some things where we do want to
we want we want to say I don't want to
do that anymore but it's to integrate
ourselves better
so rationality that's not integrated
with emotions neither one is really
doing doing a very good job that right
right and so if we look at our the
opposite version of this would be a
still Manning and you're looking at to
try to make the best argument for it and
so whenever you are are looking at a
philosophical school or an idea that it
is beneficial for all to try to present
the idea or argument in the best way
possible and I feel like we will do that
whenever we can yeah that's a commitment
we can make which will probably fail
that plan but that's what we got two of
us we can catch catch it when we when we
mess up that way all right right but
going back to the to the question so
being able to set boundaries and then
being able you know if you think about
what it takes to enforce boundaries
anytime the with some people anytime you
put up a boundary that's like invitation
to them to try to cross it right and so
if you're going to set a boundary you do
have to be prepared to say there'll be
some consequences or sanctions if you
don't do this I will talk with you
anymore or if you're stuck living with
somebody I suppose use a little listen
I'm just gonna go in another room and
I'm not going to engage with you if
you're acting this way and and you could
do that in in a variety of different
ways you could do it in kind of a petrol
in a way like I'm not gonna I'm not
going to do anything with you now you
know or you can just be very firm and
and just stick to it and say listen you
know I I want to be treated in a certain
way this is a value to me if you care
about me you're gonna respect that and
then probably the first time the person
will come up with some nonsense excuse
oh well you know I I get to do this
because blah blah blah blah blah but
maybe if you keep doing it enough and
again this sounds like it's putting too
much pressure on the you know the the
person who's being negatively affected
to do the one but that it that is what
they have to do
this kind of life is you know you're not
gonna be presented with people that are
going to perfect people
exactly yeah yeah and and it's it's a
valuable skill to be able to transfer
from situation to situation so you know
first you do it maybe in a personal
relationship well then you can also do
it at work or you can do what the person
I don't know on the bus who won't you
know take their their their stuff off
their seat and let you sit down and and
you know you can do it and it's a very
valuable thing to be able to you know
bring into one's life on and this is a
perfect transition to our spiritual
practice today which is negative
visualization which sounds you know
rather negative yes but it's the the
trade-off the the better that we can
it's the opposite of like positive
thinking and positive thinking is like
you know everything's going to work out
everything is fine like that meme with
the dog in the house yeah all right this
is fine I think as what the dog is
saying right yes
yeah negative visualization it's not to
be morbid it's not to dwell on painful
or troubling or whatever you know
negative modality we want to think about
things for their own sake it's to do it
in order to have a better life so I'll
let Dan I see him queuing up a passage
right here from Marcus Aurelius I'll let
him bring up one of the classic forms of
it yeah so this is from book 2 section 1
of Marcus releases meditations when you
wake up in the morning tell yourself the
people I deal with today will be
meddling ungrateful arrogant dishonest
jealous and surly they are like this
because they can't tell good from evil
but I've seen the beauty of good and the
ugliness of evil have recognized the
wrongdoer has a nature related to my own
not of the same blood or birth but at
the same mind and possessing the share
of the divine and so none of them can
hurt me no one can employ in
locate me in ugliness nor can I feel
angry at my relative or hate him we are
both born to work together like feet and
hands and eyes and the two rows of teeth
upper and lower to obstruct each other
is unnatural to feel anger at someone to
turn your back on him
these are obstructions yeah so this goes
beyond just negative visualization the
first part is negative visualization
then he brings in these reminders about
how he can deal with the the people and
and somebody might say oh Marcus man he
was a jerk you know look at how badly he
talked about everybody well no he's
being very realistic you know he was he
was an emperor so think of him as like a
CEO of a vast thing like Apple unless
you just surround yourself with yes
people who you now you're surrounding
yourself with people who are lying to
you so you may as well say I'm gonna
encounter Liars you're gonna have people
like doing all sorts of crazy stuff that
they they shouldn't be doing and they're
not doing it because you know they they
just only made innocent mistakes some of
them are actually bad people you know so
you know thinking about like every day
is it better to think in the morning
like I'm gonna get to work and
everything's gonna go perfectly well or
on and then you get in and someone cuts
you off in traffic and you're like I was
expecting everything to be perfect but
now the reality is that didn't happen
versus there's like Oh on you know what
is it thinking oh I'm gonna get into an
accident because there are stupid
drivers around everywhere and then you
get to work and no one hit you and say
like oh that was a lot better than what
I had expected in the first place my
outcome is better than what I expected
yeah and it doesn't necessarily have to
be quite so dramatic it could be well
I'm gonna get stuck in traffic and
people are gonna honk at me from behind
and there's nothing I can do about it
and that bothers me
and then then you can start thinking
about whoa what there's there's things
you can do in negative visualization so
one is you can think about this thing
that I'm visualizing why do I see it is
so bad and if you examine it kind of
slowly and carefully you can see well
maybe actually it
isn't that bad I'm just typically
reacting as if it's the end of the world
you know I think about public speaking
right great fear of a lot of people so
you have to give a talk a presentation
at work
and and you're like ah is gonna be
terrible you know I I'm I'm gonna start
sweating and then people are gonna see
it and I'm not gonna pronounce the words
right and people are gonna laugh at me
eh you can run all these sort of things
through your mind and yeah some of them
might actually happen but is it gonna be
the end of the world if they do I mean
how many other people have you seen
present where they didn't say everything
perfectly and then people at the end
were like oh good presentation mm-hmm
you know it wasn't perfect but it
doesn't have to be perfect right and
then another good benefit of this is the
idea that you know if these things that
though that you had thought were bad
actually do happen now you're already
prepared because you've already thought
through how you should be acting step by
step instead of being thrown into the
the middle of the arena without
preparation yeah having thought is gonna
be perfect yeah yeah you can you you
know I had a client a long time ago who
was a very high performer and he he was
struggling with anger issues
yeah I do a lot of work with that and he
wasn't having the usual kind of anger
issues where people lose control and
they say something they shouldn't say
instead it was just that he was in a
very competitive environment and people
would try to push his buttons and he
found himself not and this makes perfect
sense not able to think through complex
solutions adequately and to articulate
them at the level that he wanted he was
he was like a c-suite executives mm-hmm
so he had very high expectations of
himself and so I suggested to him
negative visualization I said listen
every time you're gonna go into one of
these meetings take three minutes
beforehand in your office and just you
know visualize these people deliberately
trying to get you riled and you know how
you can respond to it how you can how
you could not respond to it mm-hmm
and he did that and it
I'm out quite a bit you know cuz you
know sometimes your response is worse
than the original thing in the first
place you know actually that's so this
is this kind of an interesting thing to
get close to go out one of the things we
can actually talk about for future shows
is when responses that are trying to fix
something actually make it much much
worse right yeah
and why that's the case and how to how
to recover so it doesn't go from one
calamity a small calamity to a larger
calamity to eventually the whole
building falls down you know gonna you
know save your losses or cut your losses
there we go yeah oh hey but is there
more that we should say about negative
visualization about how people could do
it I mean I think one thing we could say
is it's a practice that you can do jut
like we said before you go into a
situation that you think you're gonna be
challenged like writing in the morning
or you know meeting with co-workers but
it's also something with Stoics thought
you ought to do daily right right why so
you know there's certain life events
that will happen to all of us eventually
you know we will all you know lose a job
we'll all lose a pet we'll all lose a
loved one you know none of us are
immortal here and so at some point in
time we are going to be presented with
these hardships of our life and we
should be prepared to actually deal with
them in a you know a not incredibly
emotionally charged way before we
actually have to interact with the
experience in the first place yeah so
we're not just reacting on the basis of
what we've got you know right in front
of us we we can behave rationally
you can say and not rationally in the
sense of not having emotions but you
know still keeping things in proper
perspective and and yeah and you're
right everybody that we know so this is
kind of a downer to go out on but
everybody that we know either we're
gonna die before them or they're gonna
die before us so we're gonna die at the
same time so you got to be you know
willing and able to deal with that sort
of thing and there's all sorts of other
things where negative visualization
doesn't have to necessarily be
visualizing death every day but so but
the good thing is we're here right now
yeah that's what's important at the
moment so on we are you're gonna be a
wrapping up here um I'm Dan Hayes once
again and Gregg Sadler and we have a
lovely outro music by our friend Scott
truly there we go thank you very much
for this inaugural episode of wisdom for
life from River West radio
[Music]
you